boudé par le fonds monétaire
international la tunisie en pleine crise
financière lance un appel à ses
partenaires arabes pour boucler son
budget 2021 un trou de 2,8 milliards
d'euros que le pays espère combler grâce
à l'aide de l'arabie saoudite mais aussi
des émirats arabes unis plombées par une
économie en berne et un taux d'inflation
hors de contrôle tunis semble jouer ses
dernières cartes pour éviter la
banqueroute le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis pacem chebi
une économie qui ne crée plus de
richesses un taux d'inflation impossible
à maîtriser des investisseurs étrangers
inscrits aux abonnés absents la tunisie
elle semble traverser la pire crise
financière de son histoire après la
pandémie de kobe 19 qui a mis le pays à
l'arrêt le privant des indispensables
recettes touristiques et l'oubli j'en
elle a multiplié les emprunts le coup de
force du président ça y est j 25 juillet
dernier semble avoir plongé davantage le
pays dans la crise en 2021 la dette du
pays atteint 37 milliards d'euros
dépassant de loin son pib qui frôle les
30 milliards d'euros selon des sources
officielles près de 70 mille entreprises
ont dû mettre la clé sous la porte ces
deux dernières années c'était fermeture
qui ont eu de lourdes conséquences sur
le taux de chômage qui atteint
aujourd'hui les 18 % contre 14 9% en
2010 9 face à des caisses vides et des
pourparlers à l'arrêt avec le fonds
monétaire international
tunis a annoncé l'ouverture de
négociations avec des pays amis
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis un rapprochement inévitable selon
l'économiste as d'inside and pour éviter
au pays le recours à la planche à
billets autrement dit la création de
monnaie a injecté dans l'économie si
national d'écouté et n'y en a que deux
solutions possibles puisque les
pourparlers et les négociations avec le
fmi sont à l'arrêt total depuis le mois
de mai donc il ne reste que deux
solutions ou la possibilité de mobiliser
très rapidement
des ressources en devises auprès des
pays amis et frères qui se sont déclarés
à plusieurs reprises disposée à soutenir
la tunisie à aider la tunisie et tout ça
et là on aurait besoin d'à peu près
trois milliards de dollars sur le traité
confère si on n'arrive pas à mobiliser
c'est faux parce que d'un mobiliser ces
fonds ne fera qu'aggraver les dettes est
la dette extérieure de la tunisie mais
si on n'arrive pas à mobiliser
aujourd'hui il ne reste rien que la
planche à billets mais la planche mais
c'est très dangereux sa planche à
billets peuvent faire exploser
l'inflation la planche à billets peut
faire chuter gravement la valeur de la
monnaie nationale 10 nabeul à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur
la façon d'essayer de s'en sortir en
fait c'est de développer très rapidement
de la finance complémentaire pour 2021
pour qu'on sache où moi comment l'état
va couvrir ses besoins en dépenses
courantes justement jusqu'à la fin de
l'année une loi de finances pour 2022 et
revenir en toute vitesse pour essayer de
faire bouger les pourparlers avec le
femi l'étau se resserre autour de la
jeune démocratie qui doit faire face
aujourd'hui un défi financier de taille
celui de sa dette publique et extérieure
une situation critique qui pourrait
mettre en danger le projet de la tunisie
est celui de sa transition démocratique
plus que jamais menacé